what's up everyone bang bang will
clemente and i didn't get a chance to
sit down this week as we usually do for
our weekly conversation so i'm gonna
break down a couple of the charts that
he included in his weekly blockwear
email first let's take a look there's
been a three month long downtrend dating
all the way back to november for
bitcoin's price it recently went ahead
and broke out of that now it doesn't
mean that we're in the clear there's
still a number of different resistances
that we need to claim the first being
right around forty thousand dollars
seven hundred but then we've gotta get
the forty seven thousand dollars both of
those important numbers in terms of
bitcoin continuing in a bull market
momentum then if we jump and we look at
the open interest what we can see is
that bitcoin's price has been drawing
down over the last three months but that
open interest has remained relatively
high normally when price draws down
you'd expect that there'll be a wipeout
of the open interest we haven't seen
that and so that could tell us one of
two things either there's still some
leverage in the system or what's more
likely is that there's some leverage but
it's on the short side that people could
be hedging their positions and therefore
it's worth paying attention to not
something to be fearful of yet but
definitely not what you would expect
when the price gets wiped out the way
that it has then if we jump all the way
and we start looking at actually the
open interest using bitcoin as
collateral what we can see is that
traders have been switching out their
bitcoin that used to be used as
collateral for stable coins now this is
important because ultimately if they're
using bitcoin as collateral it's got
this negative convexity to it there's a
very high probability that you could see
kind of these washouts these
liquidations where price goes down very
very significantly very very quickly but
now all of a sudden when you start to
actually migrate from bitcoin to stable
coins in those margin contracts is a
much healthier backdrop for the mark for
the market structure from a macro
perspective you would expect in these
situations to have less volatility to
the downside stable coins are stable
hence the name stable coins and so
bitcoin as collateral ends up being a
little bit more risky from a price
standpoint if we then jump and will
breaks down the on-chain metrics using
the entity-adjusted a-sol metric this is
a seven-day moving average and what he's
showing here is that the younger and
younger the coin is the more likely it
is being sold and so this is exactly
what we saw in 2021 basically from
february and march all the way through
the summer until july and august we saw
a big price drawdown and all it was was
the short-term holders those people who
had just bought bitcoin the weak hands
they were turning and they were selling
they were dumping their coins in the
market and they're being bought up by
the people who've been around the
veterans the strong hands and that's
what we continue to see here in this
metric then if we jump and we actually
look well what the hell are the
short-term holders doing these people
have held bitcoin for less than 155 days
what you can see is that the short-term
holder realized price continues to trend
down that means that those coins that
were previously bought at higher prices
are now being sold at a loss the
short-term holders have weak hands
they're selling their coins at a loss
and they're getting out of the market
then if we go and we look what the
short-term holders are selling what are
the whales doing as you would expect the
whales are gobbling up as much bitcoin
as possible they continue to accumulate
more and more and more and we can see
that those whales every time they start
to buy in the past we have seen a
massive price increase in the future
history may not necessarily repeat but
it is important to understand short-term
holders are selling and whales are
accumulating right now and then if we go
ahead and we look at the mayor multiple
what we can see is that this metric
which compares the bitcoin price
relative to the 200-day moving average
the potential upside far outweighs the
potential downside you've probably seen
will clemente tweeting about this tons
and tons and tons online it's something
he's got pretty deep conviction and i
tend to agree with him that using all
these various metrics that the
asymmetry available in bitcoin today is
more likely to the upside than it is to
the downside and then lastly we can look
at dormancy flow we've seen everyone
from fidelity to will and blockwear and
other analysts all talking about this
dormancy flow the reason is that it
recently reached the fourth lowest value
in bitcoins here uh history so the
fourth lowest value in bitcoin's history
for germany flow and so if you think
about asymmetry it is very unlikely that
we get in a situation where it's so
oversold that there's still so much
asymmetry to the upside and so it's hard
to be bearish here but again all these
metrics are individual data points they
don't necessarily make up a true story
they don't necessarily make up the full
story you've still got to be able to do
your own research this is not financial
advice from will from blockwear or
myself but understanding what these
metrics are showing you understanding
what they've meant historically puts
together a really compelling picture of
where the market is now whenever there's
tons and tons of fear and the on-chain
metrics are this bullish as we saw
during the summer of 2021 usually it
ends up turning out pretty good for the
people who can control their emotions
who can keep a long time horizon view
and can simply chill out
there's lots and lots of fear in the
market but ultimately bitcoin just
continues to produce block after block
after block of transactions and all of
these underlying fundamentals they're
really damn bullish
i hope that you guys enjoyed this
breakdown if you haven't already
subscribed to the blockwear newsletter
or follow will on twitter i highly
suggest you do both you can find links
to his twitter or to the newsletter in
the description below and we'll be back
next week with me and will both talking
about on chain metrics all the
derivatives and the macro environment
every friday and so i hope that you'll
join us then until then i'll see you
guys next week